everyone is really excited and totally
getting along what makes this film a
success to you I love my life I love my
freedom I love my Independence that's
kind of sad that I don't want to be in a
throuple I don't even want to be in a
couple I don't want people to go to the
movies straight people lgbtq people and
just have a great freaking time at the
movie theater and laugh a lot and be
moved and also see a story that I think
for a lot of people will be you know a
story that has all the elements of
comedies and Jet appet's house stolar
comedies that you love but at the same
time unlike anything you've ever seen
before so film is really throwing me
back to almost like the Heyday of the
rom-com this feels new and fresh and
very damn exciting oh my God that's
Aaron he's very hot well I think that
you they come and go but I think the
audience always desperately wants them
so people talk about like is the rom-com
dead and that's usually just because we
hadn't gotten a good one in a while but
when there's a good one people are
really psyched Luke you know this is
huge for you you come from this Hallmark
world I think I called you the Hallmark
King prince prince doing Hallmark films
is something that's huge for so many
people's careers Hallmark was a place
for me to shine I think truly I am
grateful to Billy for saying
take all the skills you've learned from
making these Hallmark films and we now
have a place for you here because the
truth was until these men and Universal
decided that there was a place for me to
tell my authentic story I couldn't
foreign
[Music]